governor steve sisilak thank you so much
for joining us
um let's start with president donald
trump he called you
a political hack told his supporters to
tell your governor to
open up your state your response
well i think that i don't know where he
comes up with the political hack i
thought he was talking about his golf
game or something i don't know
uh you know i don't know how i can
respond to president trump and what he's
his actions were selfish reckless
irresponsible
he jeopardized the health and safety
of every person that lives in the state
of nevada and there's just
no excuse for what he did i mean he knew
what the rules were
those rules were developed in
coordination with the white house
i mean the populated the limited
gathering space
if you were a red zone it had to be 10
yellow you could
25 we made it 50. he knew what the rules
were
and chose willfully to just disregard
him
and then his comment that he wasn't
worried about
you know getting a virus well i'm not
worried about him getting a virus i'm
worried about the three million people
that live here
getting the virus and i just think it
was very very selfish of him to do what
he did
what about the criticism that the
protests
that have happened the protests that
have been happening
don't get as much criticism
well the protests get plenty of
criticism the difference is that you
have a business let's take for example
a gathering businesses we can regulate
uh because they're licensed
and you go in like a casino could not
have what they did at that manufacturing
facility
uh because they have a gaming license
and they know what the rules are
but you can't control the casinos are
having a real problem
if you're inside the casino you're gonna
follow the guidelines
you walk out on the strip after you
leave one casino walking to another one
or you walk on fremont street there's
really nobody in charge of you when
you're out there
we don't have law enforcement handing
out tickets there's not a group of
people that are
giving violations or ambassadors are
just saying you know you got to put your
mascot and you got to socially distance
we don't have any of that you know we
count on people being responsible
and unfortunately in this case they
simply were not irresponsible
were not responsible they were
irresponsible
the president is saying you were behind
this effort to make sure
his rallies and campaign events did not
happen you said you were not part of
that
the next question is no one from your
office
no one from your administration made any
phone calls
no one made any phone calls with these
rallies you know i read about them in
the paper
and online just like everybody else did
people have to understand vanessa we
that every county is different you know
whether you're
washoe or clark or there are two big
ones or
urban counties or rural counties you can
get out in the white pine esmeralda and
so forth elko
the the requirements in those counties
are different than they are
in the big counties so we allocated
responsibility
and flexibility to those counties that
come up with rules
and to enforce their rules given the
circumstances that we have now some came
from the federal government to the state
and the state gave them to the local
authorities and whatnot
but they make those calls now i don't
know
who the trump campaign or whoever it
might be called at the airport
both in tahoe both in reno and in las
vegas
and thank goodness those businesses were
responsible enough to tell them no
it would be going against the governor's
directive if we did host a rally like
that so
i don't know where these locations that
he's talking about even are
and what he said uh it's i have no clue
so there's already concern about labor
day weekend
possibly causing a spike with covid19 we
don't know yet because of the numbers
um now with this rally particularly the
one
held indoors in henderson you saw the
video
how nervous are you about our numbers
going up
oh it's not a question it's inevitable
our numbers are going to go up i mean
it's not a question if they're going to
go up from labor day they haven't gone
up thus far
because we're only a week out you know
we'll be another week out
and our numbers will go up there is no
doubt in my mind
that two weeks from now you're going to
see a surge in cases
in as a result of these two rallies one
that was held up in minden
and the one that was held in henderson
the one in henderson it couldn't have
been worse
it's a confined area there's not a lot
of circulation in there
a lot of people were not wearing masks
i'm sure some of the people behind the
camera put them on
when they were taking shots but you
looked at the audience all the views i
saw people were not
basically mostly wearing masks they
weren't distanced
they were large groups and they're a lot
of
uh particulates are coming out they're
hollering they're chanting they're
cheering
that sort of thing which helps spread
the virus that's what spreads
it uh but what happens is
vanessa people got to understand we have
just started to
plateau and to go down in some of our
our hospitalization our positivity and
whatnot
we're desperately trying to reopen our
economy
to reopen more and more businesses to
expand their ability to
bring people back to work and to make a
living and what he did
by having these rallies hinders our
ability
to increase capacity in restaurants
in churches in various businesses
because
somebody is selfish enough to come in
for their own good now everybody's going
to suffer as a result of that
and our economy is not going to open
back up as quickly as it would have
that's just not right should the city of
henderson done
more to prevent that and to make sure
that did not happen
well you know i i can't uh criticize the
city of henderson i mean they sent him a
letter ahead of time and said don't do
it
and then i can't imagine how president
trump says he doesn't know what applied
to him i mean they sent a letter
to the organization and said you can't
do this uh
what can the city henderson do they find
the organization the
landlord the person who offered the
building mr ahern who
had the first one that was on sahara
where he broke the rules
uh he they fined them for all the
violations that happened now the state
still has enforcement authority through
our some of our regulatory bodies
that are looking at all these instances
but henderson did what they could i mean
this is in a matter of playing gotcha
this is a matter and it's not a matter
of trying to
get revenue this is a matter of trying
to get our economy back
on track to get people back to work
to get people in businesses opened up so
that our economy can get going again
and the selfish reckless actions
of this individual of the president are
going to set that all back and that's
very very unfortunate
people have sacrificed a lot vanessa to
get us here you know they've gone
without visiting their parents in
hospitals
and without you know being able to see
with funerals and with weddings and
you know and now that all the sacrifices
they made can be undone by these
reckless actions
the president is saying you're trying to
steal the election
coming up in november um what's your
response to that and this misinformation
about the election well that's typical
that
you know it's just got to always be
about somebody else you know it's trying
to do something
we have what an election that is going
to be conducted in a fair
a safe and inaccessible manner so that
people don't have to decide between
casting their vote and contracting
covent during the primary we had decides
that people had to wait hours
i don't want that to happen i don't want
long lines i am confident that the
secretary of state
and the various registrars are capable
of running an election
then as the post office can't deliver
ballots i mean
the post office will get the ballots in
everybody's hand they'll get them out
there
nobody is looking to steal an election
but we are looking to make an election
that everybody can participate in
i just have two more questions the
request by nevada for funding for
the national guard to keep them here
with the covid19 response was turned
down
what's your response to that well you
know i mean some of the states were
given 100
we were not given it i asked repeatedly
probably half a dozen times
for a state like us that's a lot of
money it's seven or eight million
dollars of that money is gonna have to
come from somewhere else
because the guard has been indispensable
we can't do it without the guard i mean
they're at all of our testing sites
they're helping us behind the scenes
with a lot of things but the president i
guess if he's
likes you and you're his friend he
follows the rules in your town and
doesn't break them and gives you the
money and if he doesn't you don't get it
so
unfortunately the state is suffering as
a result of his
decision to not treat nevada fairly okay
and last question
uh just for nevadans who are
frustrated by what's happening with our
economy here
with covet 19 um the first one
you know about unemployment there's a
lot of frustration there
the second is some nevadans see these
restrictions
for example you could get your nails
done but there were still some
restrictions
on bars what would you say to nevadans
who are
frustrated i understand people have
frustrations
these were not just businesses that were
picked here and there
this was done after extensive study and
work with the center for disease control
and fema that came forward with these
recommendations with what the white
house said that the initial
response was that the biggest spreading
area was mars
because people congregate there you go
to a bar
to socialize to meet people they have a
good time you don't go to a bar
to sit by yourself and have a hamburger
and a beer and go back home
you go to a restaurant usually for that
uh it was deemed that restaurants could
be okay if we put people outside at
reduced capacity
we are following science and the best
guidelines
in order to decide what businesses to
open up nail salons and hair salons and
eyelashes and all that stuff you know we
we finally got them opened up
uh under some restrictions and i think
things are better we got some people
back to work
dieter has been a challenge uh you've
got to understand that our deter system
has been in place has been
underfunded for decades this is what i
inherited it has
never had to deal with this many people
i mean we have got
we are just overwhelmed with claims and
with situations
and then when you add on to that the
fact that
when the federal government says to you
okay you distribute the money
and the extra 600 but if you make it if
somebody fraudulently gets the money
the state of nevada has to pay the
federal government back well
now it's my responsibility the state and
the taxpayer we don't have the money to
pay back
to make sure that we're not paying
people unfairly and fraudulent claims
now nevada is unique uh not a lot of
states don't have income tax we
we don't have an income tax here the
states that have an income tax have a
database
they use that database to
cross-reference with their claims so
they could tell if somebody was really a
resident
in that state and they knew whether or
not it was a fraudulent or legitimate
claim
we don't have that so we have to check
those one at a time
to make sure that somebody was a
legitimate claimant we're working our
way through that
it's been a difficult complicated
process but i'm confident that
the foreseeable future you'll see more
and more of these claims adjudicated and
we'll work our way out of it but
the citizens have done the people
residents have done a remarkable job
i mean the vast majority you're seeing
if you go to a
a restaurant or a grocery store whatever
it might be they're wearing their masks
they really are practicing social disney
thing and i know some people want to
make it into a political statement but
it's not a political statement masks are
not partisan
masks are you know uh
just it's a medical thing to get through
we are constantly looking
to improve the situation to address
people's frustrations that we
have uh we're gonna have some
announcements in the next couple weeks
upcoming as it relates to that
and some of the restrictions and whatnot
that we have in place and hopefully
people will be more
uh i guess relaxed and understanding of
the situation but
six months ago this started i mean we
finished up a school year with kids
on distance education we're back to
distance education
it's been a tough time for everybody
it's been a really tough time it's
it's been a tough time for me it's been
a tough time for my family for my
administration
but all the work that was put forward to
try to get us there to have
one individual who decided to be so
arrogant and reckless
that he's going to risk everybody's
well-being is just
something that i'm not happy about and i
made those feelings clear but i will
continue to fight for
all the residents of nevada